et si la république en marche perdait sa
majorité absolue à l'assemblée nationale
un nouveau groupe de députés devraient
tenir dès la semaine prochaine en
attirant des députés de divers partis
dont cédric villani matthieu orphelin
ancien membre de la république en marche
ce nouveau groupe pourrait rassembler
une cinquantaine de députés en tout et
cela pourrait donc provoquer une perte
de la majorité absolue des marcheurs
objectif répondre à l'urgence écologique
moderniser la démocratie et réduire les
inégalités sociales et territoriales
on en parle tout de suite avec alexis
poulain journaliste et cofondateur du
site
le monde moderne bonjour alexis poulain
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france qu'aux révèle la formation de ce
nouveau groupe
révélée par les échos une fracture de la
reine le début d'une vague de dissidence
l'affaiblissement dans marche
je ne pense pas que peut-être vous
surprendre mais mounir mahjoubi avait
dit en 2017 lors de la prise de pouvoir
de cette majorité énorme qui était la
république en marche qu'il fallait
qu'elle organise à la fois la majorité
et l'opposition pour éviter que les
idées se retrouvent dans la rue on a vu
qu'ils ont été incapables d'organiser
l'opposition et on a eu les gilet jaune
pendant deux ans ils sont toujours là et
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression c'est un ticket pour jouer
encore pour certains marcheurs qui se
rendent compte que la planche est pourri
que ça va être très compliqué de
défendre l'éthique est on l'a vu lors du
premier tour des municipales
l'éthique est en marche était honteuse
elle était cachée des affiches de
campagne il fallait surtout pas se
montrer de la majorité présidentielle
donc j'y vois plutôt une manoeuvre pour
scinder faussement un groupe pléthorique
de députés playmobil godillots comme on
les appelle et pour organiser une fausse
opposition une opposition de façade et
capter tout l'espace médiatique et le
débat et en saas c'est assez habile mais
c'est ça va durer pas longtemps et je
pense que ceux qui ont choisi de
rejoindre là puisque en marche au début
il ya évidemment beaucoup de gens qui
sont déçus mature feu là en fait partie
je pense qu'il attendait autre chose que
cette majorité où il faut signer dire
oui à tout et ne pas avoir de voir
certains ont voulu aussi avoir des
ambitions personnelles comme cédric
villani par exemple
hors de la mairie de paris les élections
de la mairie de paris et ils veulent
donc compter ou avoir plus de visibilité
dans le débat donc il s'agit à la fois
pour certains d'un enjeu de survie
politique de visibilité pour d'autres de
recyclage de 10 rebonds et bien vu que
c'est d'étiquettes du nouveau monde
elle est complètement foireuse excusez
moi du terme j'en change où je fais
semblant de changer et qu'est ce qu'il
ya de plus facile pour changer et bien
on repeint en vert avec l'écologie parce
que tout le monde est d'accord c'est des
messages simples écologique aux
constructions à mettre davantage des
citoyens au coeur du projet c'était
rappelez-vous le projet démarré le
maquereau c'était un mensonge et bien là
on remet en scène cette fausse
organisation de l'opposition pour
continuer à jouer avec les français dans
les échos un an les colonnes des échos
ce que l'on comprend c'est que la
création de ce nouveau gros risque de
remettre en cause la majorité
présidentielle au sein de l'hémicycle
vous vous pensez que c'est plutôt
stratégie pour séduire justement les au
niveau de l'écologie
oui c'est tout à fait c'est pour ce
tournant préparer 2022 dès maintenant
préparer aussi ce gouvernement d'union
nationale chère à matthieu orphelin qui
passe son temps à dire il est temps de
faire un gouvernement d'ouverture etc
c'était le principe de la république en
marche rappelez-vous ni droite ni gauche
on a fait venir
eh bien les seconds couteaux du ps de l
air de droite et de gauche pour faire un
parti finalement d'affairistes et
d'arrivistes dont certains sont
aujourd'hui mis en examen dont certains
ont quitté l'armée et mais ce qu'on voit
c'est que ça n'a pas fonctionné ça n'a
pas marché
certains veulent retourner au sein de
leur grande famille d'origine que ce
soit la gauche sociale démocrate ou bien
les républicains et puis il se rendre
compte que voilà ce ticket gagnant qui
est l art est même devenu un ticket
perdant voir disqualifiant compte tenu
des violences qu'on a pu voir lors des
années de quinquennat des modèles macro
et puis des couacs dans la gestion de
cette crise sanitaire qui ont été comme
vous l'avez rappelé une catastrophe ça
emmanuel macron ça signifie quoi pour
lui la création de son nouveau groupe
pour lui c'est ce que je dis c'est
l'organisation de cette fausse
opposition cette opposition de façade ça
permet de jouer avec les égos des uns et
des autres
ça va lui permettre de se débarrasser
des loire philippe par le haut en créant
ce faux gouvernement d'union nationale
cette fausse ouverture en repeignant en
vert écolo un peu de ces mesures qu'il
avait déjà pour redonner du souffle à un
quinquennat qui est pour moi déjà finie
depuis longtemps mais comme ça marche
comme la cinquième le père mais puisque
mal macron bénéficie de l'immunité
malgré le nombre de plaintes qui
s'accumulent contre le premier ministre
et les ministres dans la gestion de
cette crise on parle de plus de 60
plaintes je crois eh bien ça va
permettre de continuer et de faire comme
si tout allait bien madame la marquise
alors que en réalité si on voulait
associer les français et faire un vrai
gouvernement d'union nationale
il faudrait faire une dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale organisé des
élections dès maintenant et avoir un
parlement représentatif ce qu'il n'est
pas aujourd'hui j'aimerais que vous
commentiez encore les propos du chef des
députés la m gilles legendre qui dit
qu'aucune annonce officielle dans le
sens de la création de ce groupe n'a été
fait je vous invite
je nous invite tous à la plus grande
prudence il ajoute qu'il y verrait
double rupture
oui c'est il est dans son rôle
évidemment puisque lily wood comme on
appelle ça c'est à dire qu'il est là
pour tenir les députés de la république
en marche qui eux ne tiennent plus alors
il faut organiser tout ça des deux côtés
bien sûr montrer quand même une certaine
cassure et comme je vous le dis au sein
de ce nouveau groupe qui va se créer il
y aura des ambitions personnelles celles
de matthieu orphelin celle de cédric
villani et bien d'autres et puis il y as
derrière l'ombre de nicolas hulot qui a
sorti cette tribune politique descends
descends trucs pour changer le monde
sans le changer vraiment vous aviez
laurent berger enfin tout le monde est
en train d'avoir de l'appétit pour 2022
de se dire qu'il va falloir faire
quelque chose qu'il va falloir enrobé la
suite de ce quinquennat sauver le soldat
macron pour certains alors que ça paraît
extrêmement compromis merci beaucoup
alexis poulain pour votre analyse je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste co
fondateur du site le monde moderne merci
à vous